julio tehran today tough time last time
out there overthrowing the baseball
we'll have mookie bets leading things
off and right bets groundswell to third
base rendon has it
come on down that's what you want to see
all afternoon for julio tehran is
getting ground balls there's ballinger
two outs and a man at first there's a
shot on one hop it's at fletcher he was
playing him perfectly in the outfield
and he throws over to la stella and the
inning ends on a 6-3 ground out it's the
fifth start for dustin may monday
against san diego two runs over six
innings and what was a kind of a tough
luck 2-1 loss david fletcher and his
14-game hitting streak leading it off
fletcher pulls one to third there's rios
heard with the field mikes how the bench
appreciated that play they know how hard
edwin has worked at his defense
[Applause]
they're cheering him on here's chris
taylor to lead things up against julio
tehran and he checks his swing and taps
it right back near the mound fumbled oh
by tehran and he can't get the throw to
first base that was the easiest of plays
right there and tehran will commit an
error he never even got a throw to first
he just kept juggling the ball and
eventually dropped him by the time he
could pick it up and a pick off toss and
the runner is picked off so hopefully
they're going to get him this time
tehran makes up for the error by picking
off that runner at first base chris
taylor and it wasn't even close on the
pick off he was out it was a dead duck
two are gone and here is edwin rios rio
strokes one to center field trout turns
and watches it off the wall ricochets
right to him rios chugs for second and a
two out double rios is is walking around
like uh he's a little shaken up he may
have pulled something sliding in well he
slid on his right side but he is holding
it looks like the left quad since he
wants to stay in there and it looks like
he's convinced them that he's yeah all
right wow so here's matt beatty this
will be his first time up in the series
two outs runner at second
corks a line drive to right center field
for a base hit
rio set it for the plate
throw it a second
and i'm not sure that the run home
is gonna count no run no run is rios
unable to hustle across the whole played
area because of that left leg and so we
remain scoreless as we head to the
bottom of the second inning second out
on the play ohtani moves up the second
and the batter will be max stassi little
flare out the shadow left field this
could be trouble jack peterson coming in
taylor going out it falls in ohtani will
come around to score and the angels have
a one-nothing lead well that is a
well-placed sandwich
and max dassey picking up his 11th rbi
for his major league debut here is caber
ruiz one of the top prospects in the
system one of the top prospects in all
of baseball makes his big league debut
just a few weeks after his 22nd birthday
new hits one deep down the right field
line and ruiz hits it out of here
in his first career major league at-bat
a home run for camber ruiz
welcome to the majors in the biggest way
matter now is max muncie on three and
two bets leading off second in muncie
with a fly ball to right center field on
its way and gone a home run a two-run
shot for max muncie and the dodgers now
have a three to one lead who's got
hernandez's second baby at first
the ground ball into left field for a
base hit rounding third on his way home
kiki hernandez he slides in safely
an rbi single for mookie betts the
dodgers lead four to one bets down with
19 runs batted in on the year so baity
now at second base that's it first and
seeger coming up yanks one down the
right field line that's towards the
corner it is a fair ball and a home run
inside the foul pole three run shot for
seeger and the dodgers have broken it
open leading 7-1 angels trying to get to
work here against dustin may tridel
launches one out towards center field
bellinger moving back that one is gone
big fly for anthony rendon's solo shot
his sixth of the season and you gotta
start chipping away at some point at
seven or two dodgers now matt beatty who
is two for two lifts one to right center
field that ball is deep it is gone
long home run for matt beatty the fourth
of the day for the dodgers and they have
eight runs on this sunday afternoon
one gone and the batter now will be
brian goodwin goody hits one out to
right field mookie bets is going to
watch this one go and it's a solo big
fly for brian goodwood
angels get that run back gets eight to
three goody continues to swing the bat
well against left-handed pitching the
dodgers earn out of work
fletcher
grounds at the shore he's gonna do it
taylor flips to first the game is over
and the dodgers have won five in a row
and nine of their last 11